[Music]
nice
[Music]
five minutes man
no
no i'm not i'm not doing it i'm not
going out there i can't do it
you can't what i can't do it out there
there are people that are antifa they're
threatening to kill me they're going to
shoot me at this venue and pull yourself
together
i just don't want to die on stage
because they're out there they're
they're in black lock outfits and weaves
yourself
i understand this is getting heated but
i don't think that you're actually
hearing me right now my life is actually
in danger because out there these people
be a man
you're not listening to what i'm trying
to tell you okay this isn't just me
having some kind of nervous listen to
this pull yourself in guys i know
yourself
listening to what pull it together
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
who are they
oh they're my security somebody
threatened to pie me you could never be
too careful
[Music]
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
makes its stop at the smart financial
center in houston texas september 17th
buy your tickets at
louderwithcrowder.com tour today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
speedy
it's too hot you can imagine the sip
did you just fake a sip i just faked a
sip oh my god i faked it
[Music]
we're sorry it's okay
uh glad to be with you i say that every
day but it's true i am glad to be with
you yeah this is one of like this is one
of those moments in my day where when i
talk to i talk to a camera there's a
blinking red light but i can picture you
at home with no pants
i was just about to say
we have a lot to get to and by the way
the people who think when you go to that
long shot joe lewis is not dead no he's
here he just realized that he prefers to
be out there where everyone gives him
treats when i can't monitor it and lots
of pets yes he forces himself he does
he's very aggressively affectionate uh
we have a lot to get today there's
there's news that is breaking so we'll
kind of keep you abreast not with the uh
the twitter is it a twitter judiciary
hearing yeah it's a senate judiciary
committee yeah and you can explain some
of that to us because a lot of people
don't really know what's going on with
the purchase with elon musk so we'll
have more on that as it unfolds but uh
we have something today
it's exclusive and we started this
segment a long time ago we were going to
do this last week but we wanted to cross
our t's and dot our eyes let's make my
professor famous and you guys can send
your emails to uh teacher tips at
louderwithcredit.com
we have exclusive audio and
some video here of a teacher at
university of north texas who's teaching
what i believe to be in
when i say that i mean
actually is a racist a racist curriculum
and uh it's pro-censorship and uh we
actually want you guys to take part we
want your voice to be heard
because they're indoctrination factories
and uh they do this in the darkness
let's shine a light on it so we have
that we'll be talking about the swedish
elections and brian stelter just got a
harvard fellowship
that's a phrase that i spoke
in real life true story all right and
now my question before we move on again
the best thing you can do is just hit
like share and comment below that helps
with the youtube algorithm but question
is uh do you think we're going to see
more european countries as we just saw
with sweden
vote right wing swinging to the right
especially in the face of
the covet lockdowns right after that
when we when we sort of monday morning
quarterback it you're seeing a red wave
that's going to take place with the
midterms here in the united states i
think it's important to note look
everyone said let's see what happens
with florida well people have become
more right wing in florida people have
become more right-wing in sweden this
country has become more right-wing as it
relates to coveted policies the longer
we go the further down this timeline we
go people are saying you know what the
left was wrong about that so there is a
silver lining gerald a how are you sir
i'm doing well how are you better than
yesterday oh yes the food poisoning was
bad yeah
and then we have alex jones in we did it
we had to tape and ash wednesday that's
one of the things we pre-tape and uh so
i'm glad that we did because i had to
leave to go to the bathroom like three
times you're a lighter man for it i am
two and a half pounds in one day
terrible one day two and a half pounds
uh and you heard the groan
[Laughter]
but you know him you love him fastest
man on his feet and him and i are in
houston september 17th at the smart
financial center sugarland uh your
tickets at lighthouse.com tour mr dave
landa how are you sir ahoy i'm good good
sugarland did you watch the uh do you
watch the enemies uh no oh yeah i mean
yes you would have to pretend no you and
everyone else yeah okay we have a recap
oh good oh yeah yes yes no not good no
no it's a it's a pride swallowing siege
oh good good that i will never fully
tell you about i uh i i i just want to
see who took one home is phoenix sold
out is that why i'm not mentioning it uh
it's pretty close yeah that's like 50
tickets left yeah there's not much right
okay stuff people buy a bunch of those
tickets so we don't want to promote
because they're like single tickets
right like i want to sit with my friend
well you can't you should have bought
earlier i want to see who buys there's
like one seat dead center i want to see
who comes alone yes
stelter yeah it's gonna be just gonna be
wearing a harvard letterman's jacket
mustache but it turns out it's just
chocolate right oh and a giant foam hand
only the shocker no
and it's not a foam
it's just swollen yeah it's a
salt from the prior evenings goings-ons
he gained two and a half pounds yes
ah it's like freaky friday i just i lose
a little bit of weight and stilter's
like that's happening
all right
this happened the emmys uh and my
headphones are a little bit you know
what this is what happens when we reset
it's just it's it's my fault uh last
night of course the emmys and i i tell
you this because you probably didn't
know
star studded i didn't know they happened
yeah
harvard
harvard the howard halls of harvard yeah
we'll now have brian stelter amongst
them oh geez
haunting the halls of harford
that's all it is it's just a poster of
brian it's a painting of ryan stelter or
the eyes are following you because he's
behind them
men's locker room now
the emmys uh happened yesterday and uh
there were quite a few acceptance
speeches it was a weird night and here's
the thing it was also very
self-important night i think these these
are always valuable
really just to sort of recap you don't
need to watch them we we recap them so
you don't really have to because you can
see everything that is wrong with
hollywood there emits their death throws
right now it's like a baby being put to
sleep and they just don't want to go
down for a nap this is why traditional
media the traditional entertainment
industry is dying and these actors and
directors are too self-important to
realize it so here we have some
acceptance speeches from uh some of the
winners
um you know some of the most talented uh
actors uh among us it is it is a craft
um people like lizzo
i just want to say um you know i took a
lavender bath tonight
and um right before the show and it made
me swell up inside my dress
and
i'm having a hard time speaking when i
was a little girl
all i wanted to see was me in the media
someone
fat like me
black like me
beautiful like me wheezing i love how
she listed two objective descriptions
and then a subjective one
fat like me yes black like me yes
beautiful
endangered species
[Applause]
protect the class the [ __ ]
victim song
i
am a woman
i
am a no
and i wear a jim climbing rope and i
know
what show is she on
[Applause]
[Music]
um thank you so much
um
i gotta go bye
every single woman was overweight
tiffany kuzon at at mosaic and my sister
is here tonight did jennifer coolidge
host wait hold on wait hold on that's a
huge [ __ ]
[Applause]
um
why do i have these buttons here they
don't do anything
well i just really have a bunch of
buttons i disconnected that last portion
right there first off every single woman
was overweight and i don't just say that
to offend people
that's an issue and i mean the kind of
overweight where doctors would say you
have a problem and that last jennifer
coolidge who i know can be funny i'm not
taking that away from her that is
everything that is wrong with hollywood
this is one thing that just bothers me
when they're like don't play me off hold
on a second hold on and then everyone
else is cheering for she's like i'm
gonna dance like yeah you go they can't
play you off i don't want to be played
off by these corporate sponsors well
this is why
you do this awards show it's put on by
corporate sponsors who want you to dance
and then you want to maintain your
integrity as an artist you don't want to
deal with corporate sponsors go do a
show like this go do something go do it
independently i'm just i'm an artist i'm
going to keep speaking i don't deal with
corporate overlords and then they go do
a christian dior spread at macy's shut
up what'd you think you're going to have
unlimited time
they say they're just professional
martyrs in ten thousand dollar dresses
yeah and it's self-importance too it's
like yeah i'm so important i need to
talk about everybody on my list that i
have right here to say thank you to
other people we also don't care we gotta
thank people well ricky gervais said it
best he's like thank you agent thank you
god and then shut up and get off stage
i do miss didn't he used to oh that's
golden globes yeah different st i'm
saying he gave you like a you know
a template of how to do an awards speech
well it's a circle jerk let's just be
yeah i'm going to go ahead and say the
word yeah it's just a it's just an award
show where rich people tell other rich
people that they did a good job
pretending to be other people and then
[ __ ] about being played off yes you
mean there are time constraints on a
television clock yes you talentless hack
that's why you're on traditional
television
you're clinging to relevancy play ball
they always want to play ball when the
paycheck clears but then not when they
want to present themselves as an artist
with integrity shut up you get a minute
my cable ace award is pretty nice yes
know if you guys have been to my house
where i keep them i have a razzy so my
mtv's best kiss runner-up yes
i made it myself me and toby
i i bought it online off of stephen
baldwin yeah you should replace kirsten
dunst's face with yours it's kissing
upside down
oh
i bought it off tom sizemore
he needed coke that and some uh some
memorabilia from the relic yeah
uh all right
what's that we don't have anything new
so the twin at center the senate
judiciary uh hearing is still going on
uh oh you know what actually though we
do have um breaking news
[Music]
uh right now on news they're uh covering
something that people still don't care
about
[Music]
apparently cnn doesn't have audio
well there was a moment of silence oh
was it
what is this this looks like a guy who
has ventriloquist lines drawn on the
side of his face he does bring him up
full screen bring him up full screen
really quick come on quick to the punch
there look at that he looks oh my god he
looks like a comic book here he looks
like a nutcracker he looks like he just
took off his comic book eye patch yes
what a crap what is
this the queen elizabeth's coffin to be
by him
that's the first time
well then why did you bring it to
scotland as a show of force don't try
anything yes i want my corpse flown
everywhere oh and now we have an early
90s creepy babysitter very nice
where are the kids
oh my gosh i don't know i was looking
for my high tops yes
it's the hand that rocks the cradle
is mine now
my baby she's she's breastfeeding and
yeah absolutely
who is in him that rocks the cradle you
know you guys can comment below um i
always get it confused the conveyor one
but that was a good one and that was a
good movie yeah
i think she's in it yes
it is so silly cnn okay uh this brings
us right now to uh this week uh of
course uh as we discussed this our
former vice president joe biden traveled
to boston on monday
gave a series of speeches on
infrastructure and cancer
hey wasn't he going to cure it
no no no no that's what he said yes but
he said that
how do you how do you not see that as
pandering i mean that's like the kid
when he's running for class president he
says he's going to give you free ice
cream sandwiches in the cafeteria
we're going to find a cure for cancer
people like
all right i mean at a certain point
isn't your intelligence insulted i know
a lot of you voted for biden or some of
you who watched not everyone here is a
conservative you're maybe more moderate
you were tricked sorry you screwed up
you trusted him but when he said he was
going to cure cancer first off did you
believe him and second did you believe
that he would play any role in the
outcome of actually curing cancer
there's so many kinds of cancer yes like
you have to go to a foot doctor right
just as if it's if your feet hurt yeah
exactly ten acting won't cover no
so infrastructure cancer were his
speeches and uh speeches and i know i
sound like his speeches and he was
clearly like myself in top form this
brings us to another edition of this
week in biden if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
trump then you ain't black it's
frustrating
it's inconvenient
and it's bad for the environment and
there's simply no reason for it
this is the united states khmer for
god's sake
this is who we are this is not this is
not what we should be doing and i want
to thank all of you the cancer patients
survivors caregivers and don't jump from
up there okay
thank you for listening
[Music]
fastener jack come on back up
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
okay
he got lost to the podium again i know
again i know you're right i'm sorry
now to be fit he gets lost at the his
and her sink
i don't i don't know i missed gender of
the sink yeah you can use either one
what well jill had us
have two toilets put in so we could we
could poo together
it's not that he got lost on a podium
now you've probably had gigs where they
say hey you have to go back the way you
came because we're going to shut off
this exit he doesn't even have the
self-awareness that the legit the one
not the one the primary legitimate
criticism against him is that he's old
and insane and he's a demented old
circus monkey he doesn't even have the
awareness to just say oh hold on a
second this is going to look like an old
crazy moment again oh hey silly me i got
lost where where do i they didn't tell
me oh i go back that way all right
thanks again people but something so
that it makes people think all right
he's sharp enough to be there's no
self-awareness that is the best of his
capabilities the best he could think of
on the spot riffing was
huh go back to the podium and say
something well he also said something
about cancer and then said don't jump
and it's like that that's good yeah that
follows a good line yeah exactly i can't
cure cancer don't kill yourself
was it just looking at a bunch of kids
with leukemia yeah we're like we're
we're helping your cure right yeah hey
ronald mcdonald house you know what i'm
talking about yeah i don't know
starts going don reckles on them why
don't you go to alaska step on her step
on a rake hey which one of you hairless
ones want to meet john cena
i don't know when he says this he can't
see me i can still see him yeah he's
still there
he's still there it's no it's a lie oh
there's the light again
i gotta go towards it
can i just comment really quickly on his
moonshot comments like he's he's calling
this his cancer moonshot on the 60th
anniversary of you know the actual
moonshot saying we're gonna land a man
on the moon and bring him back to earth
for his cancer before we struck before
anything about how to do that
what he is saying the cancer moonshot
that the media is fawning over right now
and saying oh this is brilliant is him
basically saying we're going to cut
cancer deaths in half in 25 years now
joe but being like babe the medical
science is advancing fast enough to
probably do that on its own maybe
stretch a little bit and go well if it's
going to be a mood shot let's cure it
yeah just kidding that's very
unambitious 25 years yeah but you're
right he just there's nothing there no
and everybody's just applauding and like
oh this is brilliant before the midterms
too no less pandering to the public not
at all actually curing i mean not curing
i don't think he's he's capable of
pandering though i don't even think he
knows what he's saying well he also has
a really tough act to follow because for
all of the criticisms of you know levy
toward donald trump and by the way some
of them are legitimate of course
no one can say that the guy was not able
to think on his feet yeah you may not
like it but if that happened oh wait
they didn't tell me you're fired i'm
just kidding but seriously you're fired
you're out that's what he would make a
joke about it biden has the worst act to
follow it's a guy who really didn't use
it the first president who very rarely
used a prompter you can see it also with
his rallies that's what he was known for
he's ambitious versus a guy who cannot
think for himself that's tough that's a
tough contrast well yeah because trump
was held accountable for what he said
right i mean this guy actually kind of
can't be that's what's sad right i mean
he should be right but he's there's no
there's just no way it's like with a
child it's not their fault it's the
parents it's not it's not the former
vice president's fault it's the handlers
it is the president's fault kamala
harris he needs a rolled-up newspaper
yes
[Laughter]
it's the stair's fault that he's hitting
his head on yes go rub his nose in it
[Laughter]
oh it's the stocking cap that was too
tight yes
the candle that he fell on in his
nightgown yes
[Music]
i thought i heard something
it's my best dressing gown
now uh le this is something it's a
little bit weird it's a slow news day so
we wanted to bring this this is
exclusive okay this is something that
we've worked on for a long time and we
want to do this more often actually um
it's tough you know we've talked i can't
do any of the undercover stuff anymore
no without very expensive prosthetics
because unfortunately i get recognized
yeah you take the good with the bad it's
your fault yeah and with that there's
it's pretty much just bad i don't really
like the recognition thing no i like to
be incognito i like to fly under the
radar yeah but every time i wear an
outfit it's considered a negative
stereotype
um so uh
if and i would love for you to send your
e uh send your emails to tips uh teacher
tips at lotwithcredit.com and if you're
watching on youtube like i said hit the
like button but comment below if you
have professors like this if you are in
a class right now
this is a sort of a good little
ecosystem where we can all share this
information um now a lot of people may
wonder and i think this is a question
people often ask is it that leftists go
into the education sector
uh simply by sort of you know their
natural proclivities that maybe people
who tend to be liberal tend to be
educated in education or do they go in
because they want to actively
indoctrinate not only children but of
course college students i would say it's
more so the latter especially when you
look at a lot of the segments that we've
done and a lot of the audio recordings
that you can hear from dean's right of
admissions but you can also hear from
professors at ivy league schools we'll
get into brian stelter at harvard in a
second
why do you think they are such radical
activists
well
it's also we're at the point where we
have one generate we're one generation
removed maybe two where this was a
conscious effort on behalf of the left
andrew breitbart talked about this
marxists did uh proactively infiltrate
the educational sphere so this is where
we're actually uh i think this is the
first time launching the initiative
aimed at exposing just how unhinged
uh and how damaging it can be with some
of these i would just say frankly
immoral college professors and how awful
it can be so allow us to introduce this
new segment make my professor famous
[Music]
all right so all of this was sifted
through uh by our team here uh this
professor who's featured today famous he
should be happy about it kevin howard
from the university of north texas
that's kevin howard from the university
of north texas and the course that he is
teaching is uh diverse learners
in spring of 2022.
teaching diverse learners
why don't you just do it
yes why don't you just teach a diverse
group of people why do you need to teach
people how to teach diverse learners
uh so let's go through a few things book
anti-racist baby right you're like good
news it is right
so one of the first things that he
discusses in the syllabus is uh is
gender pronouns we'll get to this then
we have some auto audio recordings
according to the syllabus uh the class
quote will focus on structures of the
social and you'll hear the clips this is
pretty close okay social uh structures
of social and educational inequality in
particular as they relate to race class
and gender processes of power and
control and education geez it sounds
like psycho gobbly [ __ ] it does and it
is
but it's also really scary when you
actually think about what that means
control and education yes because
conservatives dominate that industry yes
it's like come on this is what they're
tilting at windmills right they try and
present as though they are this
underclass and they're fighting against
it well hold on a second you guys have
the white house
both the former vice president and the
president right you have those right now
you have obviously right now we're going
to see a red wave uh but you have all of
certainly media the entertainment
industry of abc nbc cbs which is also
abc disney right which is nbc universal
which is cbs viacom
you have warner you have control over
who are you fighting
fox news
this that's why they want to get rid of
this show because it's just because it's
competitive it beats their multi-hundred
million dollar budget shows and so they
have to say we have to fight against the
semi-fascists let's make a new term so
the reading list also includes uh such
uh
such topics uh such books you have
why talk about whiteness
oh is that rhetorical yeah no the why
then you have no pers the persistence of
gender norms then you have anti-trans
laws are making trans youth feel unsafe
it's a wordy title yeah then you have
sex sexual orientation gender identity
gender expression
that's a lot of questions a lot of
questions shouldn't your course answer
the question yeah that's true it's like
jesse ventura i'm just asking questions
what are you gonna answer i don't know
who's at tower seven do you know i'm
asking questions
okay
answer do you no ah fluoride in your tap
yeah i don't have clue i'm off the grid
right watch my show off the grid where
i'm completely on the grid and then he
also does time warp again
this guy is obsessed obviously with
gender and this is something if imagine
if you live your life and this is the
disconnect that takes place is you live
your life and you don't constantly think
about gender identity you don't
constantly think about sexual
orientation you don't constantly think
about gender expression most people
don't
but then you wonder why it's the focus
of every single show if you watch the
emmys why it's the focus of almost every
single news topic what do you think is
going to happen when people who are now
entering the workforce this is the kind
of course load
that they have to go through
he's also by the way very obsessed with
gender and with sexual orientation i
have my suspicions do you so um
i'll show it to you after actually let's
do the audio uh the audio clips first
we'll show clip k after and by the way
if you want to see more of these
segments um just hit the like button
that helps with the algorithm we would
like as many people to see these as
possible because we want your voice as a
student to be heard it really is we i
can't tell you how many people come up
to us and say what do i do with and
insert a problem in college here
everywhere everywhere we go when we do
these basically unfettered power it's
very very difficult to go to the
administration and say he's being unfair
he's targeting me it's like very hard to
prove that and so professors can just
make your life a living hell it's a
forced captive audience and just so you
know uh this professor
is every bit as radical as you might
have guessed from the syllabus so here's
professor howard discussing in his class
and some of these clips are a little bit
longer for context all of these are
available at loudouthcredit.com the link
is in the description as far as all of
the references
here is professor howard discussing
in a
not so subtly racist way
whiteness
watch televised thing is inherently
heteronormative
and inherently masculine which delves
into pure sexuality of whiteness nobody
calls it out
that's why theorists are saying it's
invisible because nobody calls it out
then it becomes
the norm
make sense
and when something is the norm if no one
points it out if no one questions it
then it's unchecked unmarked it's
invisible it's fluid it moves and we
talked about this last class right class
classes as
we understand how how's that operating
with the bourgeoisie and the folks who
are taking lands even when we come to
taking lands we think of it
even as colonization
turns out right so there are so many
pillars and so many things happening all
at once simultaneously
so let's see some of the problems there
where he says it is inherently
heteronormative to watch tv what are we
doing this is something that can't be
disproven this should not be the realm
of professors by the way in the same way
that it should not be the realm of
science
well hold on a second i don't think it's
heteronormative simply to watch tv it
doesn't matter he's made the accusation
what does that do that tries to instill
guilt in a good portion of that
classroom what do you think straight
white males how do you think they feel
in that classroom
what have you said watching television
is actually uh
afro-american normative
afro-lesbian normative
probably wouldn't go over too well
and then he talks about colonization and
again we're continuing with the guilt
and this is why you're seeing in sweden
fake racism and that is fake racism
breeds real racism
because you have a bunch of young white
men in that class who are going to go
through an entire semester of this
when you keep accusing them whether in a
hard fashion or a soft fashion or being
racist where they go you know what okay
all right fine if that's what we want to
say i guess if i don't believe that
watching tv makes me guilty as a
heteronormative i guess i'm a racist
that's what you're going to see happen
more false guilt the idea of
colonization right the people who who
took who are taking lands
do you mean the slave traders in africa
the vast majority of slaves you know
were sold they were sold into slavery by
african slave traders and by the way it
still goes on today in parts of africa
so we've just laid at the feet
in a way that cannot be proven and
certainly in a way that cannot be
questioned again because you're a forced
captive audience with this professor
guilty guilty guilty guilty guilty by
history guilty by association guilty by
your everyday activities watching
television that's heteronormative
i'm still stuck on the fact that that
was a male's voice okay so uh before we
get to the next one
i he is he he is completely just very
loosely i thought it was a student stop
stop projection he has a girlfriend in
canada uh and
we actually found some footage of him
playing no he's also he's a military man
oh
by that i mean he played a soldier in an
undergraduate play called uh about face
and uh here's a clip draw your own
conclusions
i put a huge emphasis on saving lives
fact of the matter though is that any
livestream do not replace those that
have been lost thus i am basically
lying
basically left with nothing
too trapped in a war to be at peace
is that a noose or mardi gras beads i'm
not sure
it's a garage door pull it's anal beads
this is what brought me to my final
mission
nothing heteronormative about that um
wow where's his emmy
i wouldn't i wouldn't accept it they'll
just play me off fabulous i'm an artist
sorry i meant professor how did he do
the voice so well it's just
he's an actor was he getting hung for
being black or gay i have no idea
probably probably for not being a great
actor yeah
well i'm just wondering what the plays
that was the era's equivalent of the
razzy um i'm honestly asking i didn't i
assumed that was what the play was about
right i have no idea uh seems about
right let's go with that here's the same
professor professor howard of course
discussing so now what we have is a
professor and a position of power okay
so when people talk about the power
structures that be
this is very a very common theme and i
hate it when the left they'll accuse the
like you're projecting well okay
projection is a real thing but it's not
a real thing as it relates to example uh
for disdain over like serious
perversions or serious crimes so the
left will say why are you obsessed with
pedophiles huh are you a pedophile no
that's not a real thing why are you
against gay marriage are you gay no
that's not a real thing where you do see
projection though
is in the negative behavioral patterns
especially ones that can't necessarily
be proven for example in a court of law
or through the rational socratic method
so when they say we're fighting the
power structures well hold on a second
this is an actual power structure when
you're sitting in a classroom with a
professor that is a person who has been
designated the single figure in that
classroom in power they are a king of
that classroom they can silence you they
can decide who speaks they can decide
what your grade is they can kick you out
when they want so when this guy says
heteronormative and he talks about the
powers that be
and they use that right they used it to
set set the floor set the stage in that
case floor stage same thing there was no
stage uh to then say we're we're
fighting the powers that be and that's
why i
what what well support censoring speech
here's the professor
trying to indoctrinate his students with
that dangerous message
um hey it's not playing do you wanna
have the audio on that clip
well that's weird he censored his own
speech yeah did he censor his own speech
yeah that's a little on the nose
can we have them send it to us while
we're here uh live yeah yeah okay uh so
uh he can and you know you can just
bring up the uh the transcript i guess
but uh he was talking about censoring
speech and he does everything short of
actually calling for violence which says
there's a there needs to be a lot of
noise made mm-hmm again i'm going by
wrote having watched the clip a while
ago yeah there needs to be a lot of
noise made and people don't listen
unless you make a lot of noise and this
is in discussion i think as it relates
to
trans pronouns where he's talking about
this about gender identity and talking
about how silence of course is violence
we're at that era think about it where
if you speak speech is violence and
silence is violence and then you're not
allowed to have an opinion in most of
these cases well we're way past that
you're not allowed to have an opinion
that they disagree with but even if you
have an opinion
it's violence and then if you're silent
it's violence so the only acceptable
response the only acceptable response to
the kind the kinds of indoctrinating
diatribes that you hear from these
professors and by the way they are one
and the same
as those in the media for more proof see
brian stelter just got a very honored
fellowship at harvard
you know it used to be like an honorary
degree you know it was like like a fake
black belt like a toy you got in your
happy meal it didn't really matter they
did it like oh tim allen gets an
honorary degree at u of m okay thanks
you show up now they're taking it
seriously so cosby got like 20. yes
yeah he did and it was all they were
given to him by 20 women he was a doctor
he was
he had a he had actual mds yeah well he
sure
he certainly had a phd in
pharmaceuticals i mean honestly i would
trust him more than most pharmacists on
the floor that's actually true yeah he's
good with elixirs he knew his way around
it you have to get that dosage just
right it's true or you sedate them
but they're still lively enough to you
know make it a good time yeah
here is this professor professor howard
discussing censoring speech spoiler
alert he's pro can somebody asked like
why um uh why were they spitting well
because like the speaker had a story
where
his son
transitioned
and is now identified
or she identifies as she and
the father the speaker still did not
respect that and so then when we're
talking about pronouns with respect
for
for gender
identification
then
that's why
things got
rowdy i do think that there's an
argument to be made about
about
what that sets up in the future
i do believe
and by no means am i like a violent
person right but i do believe that
here it comes
a lot of noise needs to be made
to consider change
a lot of them how does that relate to
not being a violent person oh i get it
um
if you didn't have a blowing noise some
of the standing problematic ideologies
historically would still exist does it
make sense
going further
i think this sets up a lot of
interesting
uh a lot of interesting things right
particularly
the choices on what speakers are are
going to be
um coming back
okay so let's just walk through that
really quickly and i know gerald you're
champion of the bit here to get in but
i'm not a violent person
but
a lot of noise needs to be made and i
think that opens a legitimate
conversation to what speakers ho let's
just follow that it starts with i'm not
a violent person but
and then it ends with which speakers let
me ask you have there been violent
protests over speakers on campus
of course ben shapiro that noted
jewish nazi
you've probably been on campus have you
seen violent protests on your campus
happened in berkeley at one point that's
how we came to know jake shields an mma
fighter who just had to start punching
people in antifa so in other words
within the context it gets worse keep in
mind you had the media try and run
a montage a highlight reel of me saying
that the raid of mar-a-lago is uh the
equivalent to figurative war saying of
course i'm not calling anybody to
violence in any capacity we're talking
about this is a now a political and an
ideological war where people are being
silenced by members of their government
in this case the guy is saying i am not
a violent person but a lot of noise
needs to be made especially as it
relates to speakers being allowed
on campus also they always want to have
these both ways this is the professor
notice he talks about gender here yeah
what does he say classification so
identification right
well hold on a second so i want to make
sure i'm clear on the rule book because
the theory now modern gender theory is
that doctors have been wrongly assigning
gender at birth no no
they've been identifying since the
beginning of time every biologist let
alone md
let alone a doctor let alone someone
who's just a family practitioner they go
okay penis no okay they identify
a boy or a girl there's no assigning
that's the language play when a doctor
does it and keep in mind when it's
convenient you're supposed to trust the
science when a doctor says it's a boy
that's a signing gender
but when it's yourself it's simply
identification
you can never have
a debate you can never have a rational
disagreement with these people because
they frame it in a way that does not
allow for it and this is what they do
with kids and the reason i'm bringing
this up is not just to embarrass
this professor i would very much welcome
professor howard here on this show your
students are are mad
your students
many of your students think this is
wrong and unfair hey what about the
power structures that be should you hear
their voice they don't feel like they
can speak out they think they'll get a
failing grade
they think they might get called before
they think they might be reprimanded
so let's have an honest and open
discussion here let's not do some
wordplay that's why we're doing this
students out there feel helpless let's
not act like the only other
is the trans afro-lesbian
women's studies major yeah well this is
exactly what jordan peterson was
fighting against right so the example
that he kicked off that entire segment
i'm not a violent person was a father
whose son had transitioned to become a
girl and now is a she and the father
doesn't identify
his son right previously as a woman and
that's the problem that kicks off i'm
not a violent person but if we don't get
violent essentially is what he's saying
then we'll still have some of these
problems and we would still have some of
the issues that we've had in the past if
not for violence right but the other
thing that i was i was chomping at the
bit for i was like
champing it is champing you're right
it's an equestrian term champing at the
bit i like to say chomping because i was
i always say chomping it's champing
from now on from henceforth it is
chomping i got actually my friend i'll
be honest this is the least this is the
least thing that's confusing
i i don't even know where to start you
lost me at television
[Laughter]
this guy is supposed to be a professor
and it seems like he went to the kamala
harris school for giving speeches where
he doesn't really make any sense in a
sentence and he's like it sets up some
interesting things and it's like
what are those things you're the
professor please tell me what this sets
up right it doesn't sound very
intelligent as a student i literally was
having trouble following his logic i
understand the through line that he was
saying about violence and everything
else but i couldn't understand exactly
where he was going because it didn't
seem like he knew right there's there's
no there wait no there's no they're not
teaching anything though no it's not at
all it's not it's not even an opinion
really this is when people say oh so uh
you're anti-intellectual no i'm
anti-that the idea that professors are
somehow intellectual well look there's
no accountability the only place where
there's no accountability these jobs of
course are a former vice president of
the united states liberal fact checkers
and professors no one can say anything
it's like kramer doing karate with
five-year-olds that's all it is he's in
there these kids have to listen to him
because he probably wouldn't be able to
defend his argument so professor kevin
howard from university of north texas i
would gladly welcome you on the show i
think if you're a professor who cares
about people and marginalization
you should be concerned that you have
students who feel uncomfortable and this
is something that happens all across the
country if you're a student right now
hit the like button because we hear you
we're going we're going to do our best
to use this platform uh to help you
teach your tips at lyder's credit.com
right now former vice president joe
biden is giving his cancer moonshot
speech right this is breaking okay guys
in the control room let us know if
there's anything we miss
oh boy
they're applauding me nazi facts
of the service he always opens with that
they're in boston's own
marty walsh
marty
you said marty walsh is the guy from
boston was that his little bit of maddie
that was his opener thank you to the
members of the massachusetts delegation
from whitey bulging hillary clinton
lynch keating
and uh
uh jack uh uh jake i should say
auchenklaus
should you say jake because it is jake
santa claus
and i want to thank all of you
too close survivors
he just said don't jump from up there we
had a clip of that they say this is live
reflection and remember are we sure cnn
is live right now this isn't from
earlier today it's saying happening now
what hold on look at the time stamp 4 35
p.m eastern time what is one of those
times the changes are we watching a
recorded version oh we're watching a
recorded version i'm wonderful but why
does it say happening now though on cnn
well is our i just want to make sure our
setup is back to live and it's not
because we were scrubbing for a previous
clip are we sure that we're live with
cnn right now guys it should be i'll ch
but it says 4 35 p.m it can't possibly
be live no it's not live we know that
this is yesterday
it's barely alive ah yes we were
watching something where we thought
wonderful
you know what admonish all of us all of
us i'll take that one just because i
should have made sure to have them
double check that we're live on cnn oh
that's too bad i want to go back by the
way
this entire time i've been seeing like
the dow because i knew there were some
bad inflation numbers oh no did you sell
no no no the dow looks like i bought it
it said up it's like 200 i'm like what
it's down 800.
oh good it's just off by a thousand well
i guess they jumped like i should have
known down 860. yeah inflation sucks
today i don't know if you saw that
report i've you know what i made all my
money in recently what's that i invested
in pronouns twitter good for you loaded
yeah well it's an expanding portfolio
i'm telling you it is a growing market
you would not believe how much money
i've made nope pronouns as far as the
eye can see i sold all my
about four years ago did you yep well
the thing is that they they give it back
oh you can't actually sell it off oh no
they'll throw it in your face whenever
it's convenient all right oh which
speaking of very very white like
shockingly white right brian stelter
just got a gig at harvard so less than a
month after being canceled at cnn and
again stealth this doesn't work out 200
you know what i'm going to up it from
yesterday 260 000
a year plus a signing bonus to be
determined
i don't necessarily know what the moving
stipend is like i would imagine he has
to have the furniture
partially reinforced so there will be a
ball pit from mcdonald's yes exactly
no no he asks actually he asked for a
like a loft that is ball pit adjacent oh
right he wants a good view oh jeez
he can take a dip yes watch
brian stelter now has a gig at harvard
he just announced new starting job this
is from twitter right this correct this
is an overlay from brian stelter's
twitter
personal news i'm joining the sh the
shorenstein center at harvard kennedy
school
oh i always wanted to be a kennedy yeah
this fall i'll be the walter shorenstein
media and democracy fellow convening
discussions some of which will be live
streamed grateful to nancy gibbs and her
team for the home well come on i don't
want to make for you this guy didn't
have a home
and he's going to be convening a series
of lectures on threats to democracy and
the media's responses this is a guy who
just cannot let go of the lie no don't
we already know what his response is
going to be to the media lying to the
american public he's just covering it up
and kind of carrying the water for big
tech we already know brian you've told
us about it on a show that was so bad he
got booted you know what i think a
threat to democracy is a dishonest
unaccountable media but that's just me
mr old fashioned brian you were the pied
piper of said unaccountable media yeah
someone say pie
hide hide he'd be too winded to play the
flute two pies no it's not
[Laughter]
did someone say pipe
[Laughter]
piper
oh boy brian pie and pipe because
there's nothing more effective at
bringing rats out of town than the flute
that's true it's true they cannot resist
rather love
floutest one thing i know rats cannot
resist true a good flute nice i don't
know that doesn't sound oh i'm the
expert here you know it's how yanni got
nibbled up with scurvy yes
zam fears like swiss cheese okay would
that be
you see like what's it get who's a
terrible flautist i don't even know
anymore is kenny g technically a flute
is it a saxophone it's a phone but it's
a flute sexism isn't it
i think it's a flute saxophone i am
almost
[Laughter]
okay so uh this is of course uh not the
only teaching offer that stelter did
receive and we just talked about you
have professor howard there at
university of north now you have
professor stelter this is where people
who cannot hack it in the real world and
keep in mind brian stelter not only
could not hack it in the real world
brian stelter made it simply through
brown nosing and he tried to ingratiate
himself to the one man in power again
the power structures that be
zucker over there at cnn only when that
guy he was left with nothing i look
that's one of my favorite stories of the
year when when the new guy who came i
forget his name the new guy uh the new
guy scene and i always forget the guy's
name either he came in he said we want
to go back to news and stelter and this
was rumored throughout the halls he's
like ah i'm gonna lose
everything i said we're going to go back
to news you mean i'm fired
brian we didn't say you there's more
people to fire first tuban oh stop
speaking through code say what you mean
mean what you say
cnn gtp
pq plus
and it's cancelled [ __ ]
i was really banking on that plus
oh my fans oh no no chris wallace is
like i chose the wrong time you know
who's written no you know who's the real
loser in all of this this cnn plus
debacle
is
the fan
yeah
you
it's just a grease fan it's john stealth
nobody touched my greasepad all five of
you
was someone playing with my grease fan i
have it set to level three and it was
clearly set to level two
not to be confused with my dessert fan
right which is what i have when i eat
dessert yes that's more of an open
convection oven it keeps it warm or cold
depending on what i want sometimes i
want both and i have to choose
let's just go with second brunch i get
so sweaty go follow his his instagram
it's the funniest thing ever yeah it's
nothing that a gay man would post no no
he thought he was getting a fellow at
harvard not
oh [ __ ] the worst one is
is
if you cross-reference his instagram
yeah with his wife's because she's also
a news broadcaster and you're just like
oh is she really oh yeah she's running
interference for him oh yeah she was a
broadcaster it's just so painful the
only thing the only thing better than
waking up to my wife's hot bod is brunch
that's an actual boat
no are you serious
yes the only thing waking up next to
this beard i mean wife right uh oh no he
likes food more than his uh hot bod wife
yeah i guess i mean that's the least
surprising component there he really did
mean temperature yeah
that's exactly she's because she doesn't
have her own greasepad
that's for me
i want a grease fan is that a real thing
all right so his job now at the
at the respected halls of harvard that
brings us to the top teaching jobs that
were considered by brian stelter this
week seven plus one
[Music]
you're forgotten
the chamber
all right this is again the seven plus
one teaching jobs considered by brian
stelter and you can add your uh you can
add your little uh your little ditties
your numbers uh if you comment below i
had ones that you thought we missed
because invariably there's going to be a
better writer out there
number seven top classes brian stelter
brunch 101 at devry well that seems
pretty self-explanatory you want to take
uh number six uh dave i'm surprised you
passed on that deconstructing asexuality
at wellesley oh yeah that's one that's
yeah
that's one thing you know what actually
i'm the more i think about this he's
qualified for some subjects i'm
surprised he passed modeling asexuality
yes uh gerald number five these are the
top teaching jobs considered by brian
stelter drama studies focusing on obese
john cryer impersonations and el cordon
blue wow that makes sense yeah i don't
really know that's a university yeah
well more of a trade school for the fat
yeah i mean he would it is a good
character study yeah exactly no he's the
understudy yeah he's always under
someone else who's studying yes yes oh
boy
at least on all fours
number four
gossip lies and chaps navigating upward
mobility in the modern media workplace
at columbia
well it's you know it's really more of a
road map yeah and how to get ahead it's
chaps he knows what he's doing
uh steps are out of fashion number three
dave number three is the top teaching
jobs considered by brian stelter uh
destigmatizing monkey pox in the modern
world at universidad de mexico city oh
that makes sense he's very wet he just
picked that up because he wanted to lisp
when he names the school he does yes at
universidad universidad mexico city wait
where is that
oh you tease me i'll say it as many
times as you want university dad
university dad yes
where's my universe the dad he left when
i was a boy where's my neighbor say
brunch
[Laughter]
come
you forgot the shrimps
top seven plus one teaching jobs uh that
uh uh brian still to consider number two
space exploration at texas tech uh in
and around uranus that one's childish
then again so is harvard that's true yes
and uh the number one uh teaching class
that was considered that lost out to his
class at harvard is uh how to look 57 at
37 at master class yeah there you go
that's been line one that's been our
second wave no no no no you forgot
number one you forgot plus one i don't
know i i don't want to yes you got to do
it i don't know yes
i'll do it i'll do it
architectural glory hole design history
and theory at duke university okay no
that's enough that's been our seven plus
one
[Music]
you're forgotten the chamber
and to be clear we're referring to the
gold
you know the alaska gold digging shows
where they they called their it's called
the glory hole if you're digging for
gold i'm not yeah you're trying to step
in because you can see the low level
seething a little bit yeah you can you
can see the steam
i mean if you're let's admit it it's
just funny
and that's probably what he'd be yeah
he he digs for gold that man can dig a
hole
he's the old he's the old prospector
yeah he's a very old just saying sorry
prolapser prolapse that's right he's an
old prolapser oh i think i found oh it's
everywhere
the history of gold
prolapse rush
grab my crocs we're going to the
mountains yes i'm a good sifter i'm
sifting oh these crocs are slippery oh
boy i should have worn the birkenstocks
oh no that's brian's gold commonly known
as fool's gold i feel like he's the kind
of guy that goes to like a nice
restaurant and asks if they have
cinnamon toast crunch yes yes
and the answer is always
you asked that last time
and a bib yeah
no we don't and the answer is still we
do not have a bib i'm going to have
dessert for dinner just give me
give me some thread and a couple of
children's menus i can make my own
okay five kids chicken fingers please
history channel on tonight's dining
alone this place is michelin rated just
him with a
the same with a gopro
trying to make fire with with a fondue
candle why do you have a gopro for when
you eat to touch myself later it's
dining alone history channel the time i
have to make it a hundred days
alone with the
price yeah his his version of uh alone
in the wild is alone in new york city
yes like i have to find places to eat so
that's just because people cut him a
wide berth hey speaking if you wanted to
understand this me without a camera
it's like well what's this it's just a
month yeah please just keep going back
through the drive through you're like
are you making another documentary uh
yes yeah
where's your camera and two diet cokes
did i say two i mean three do you guys
he's like doing it like you know when
you're a kid and they tell you to act
like you're not alone when a stranger
calls like does everybody who want diet
cokes
and one sprite for the child yeah
hey speaking of
of people who we can't stand at cnn in
case you wanted to see that this is just
smoke and mirrors um don lemon i saw
this morning for the first time he
wasn't in studio you know with the
studio lights yeah where he looked you
know don lemon for all the criticism
like a lot of people look weird on cnn
don lemon
dapper gentlemen he is he's well put
together man well that's what i thought
until i saw him on location at the
queen's funeral and tell me this doesn't
look like a turtle without his shell
oh my
look is he really there he's not really
there he is there they blew him there
like who should we get to cover the
queen another queen yes send him there
the queen on the queen yes
and uh here's the thing this is changing
a lot too by the way well we're talking
about this and uh we were talking about
uh former vice president biden on that
wonderful live feed earlier um
live yesterday you see what's happening
across the country and you're seeing a
lot of students i i have to tell you
there's been there's been a huge uptick
in people asking us to cover more
professors that's why we've yeah decided
to really go all in on this make my
professor famous segment because i don't
want you guys to feel like you're
unheard i don't know where someone like
you goes
and it was bad when i was in college i
don't know what it was like when you
were in college gerald but it was pretty
bad i
it's unfathomable to me now that you
have to you are forced to sit there as a
captive audience and the worst part is
often once you take that course you
don't know until you get in there
and they can you know they can sucker
punch it you have to sit there and you
have to fake it if you want to get a
grade so yeah this is something where
you're seeing a lot of younger people at
universities now the rebound effect
they're rejecting it and that's what
we're also seeing happening in in sweden
right now with the recent uh elections
and we're going to talk about that more
on mug club another 45 minutes here uh
actually we have another full hour if
you go to a lot of credit dot com mug
club it's 99 annually 69 for students
you get the wonderful hand-etched girthy
mug and uh you get the entire uh blaze
catalog and a full second half of the
show are you about to say something
better it's an active military too in
students that's right you get 69 you
just enter in that word and uh you get
that promo code and we just ask look
honor system don't claim to be a veteran
if you're not a veteran uh so share the
show hit like we love you very much
thank you we will see tomorrow's nash
wednesday with alex jones youtube piss
off
[Music]
bye